après google au tour de facebook de
refuser de payer pour les articles de
presse qui se retrouvent sur ses pages
la presse française essuie un revers
majeur le réseau social facebook ne fera
pas les éditeurs lorsqu'ils décident de
publier eux-mêmes du contenu sur sa
plateforme
même chose pour les extraits d'articles
les images ou les vidéos produits par
des groupes médiatiques que les
internautes choisissent sans leur
consentement de partager avec leurs amis
une décision qui survient quelques jours
après l'entrée en vigueur de la loi du
droit voisin qui prévoit pourtant en
europe un meilleur partage des revenus
publicitaires captées par les géants du
web
devant leur refus de se conformer à
cette nouvelle réglementation les
groupes californiens s'expose à de
nouvelles poursuites en europe
[Musique]